unfortunately I think everyone thinks
they're funny maybe and so few people
actually are I think there's a certain
type of bully humor bullies throughout
history and including you know people
who have become some of the most
powerful people in the world you know
they just use their humor to make other
people feel small and to be like every
joke they they make is that someone's
expense and almost bragging about how
much more powerful they are than the
other person and that to me is not the
greatest sense of humor to have because
while it's fun to slam your friends I
think you really don't have a lot of
empathy for the for the bully who's
using humor I think the instinct to be
self-deprecating starts when you're
young and and you know you don't take
yourself too seriously when you're not
popular and the world and your peers
don't seem to be taking you seriously
you know I remember in high school for
some reason I just heard that there was
a huge dude who was who really didn't
like me who wanted to beat me up as far
as I was concerned I had never met him
but it was just one of those things
where he had found someone smaller than
him to pick on and so I remember just
using humor to disarm him and like he
got in my face one day and I just was
like come on man I started I started
acting like really huge and tough I'm
like come on I'll take you down come on
bro come at me bro and he just started
laughing and I was like huh you're funny
man and then after that we were friends
I was getting mugged once and I just
ended up talking to the guy for 20
minutes and trying to make him laugh and
at the end of it he was like you're too
nice of a guy all right I'll see you
later that sort of skill can really come
in handy when you feel as if the world
is against you in a way to not take
yourself seriously I think the world
then
has the empathy for you you always see
it when you're taking a public speaking
class they always say start off with a
joke you know it's people don't want to
have lives where they're sitting there
being bored by people all the time and
you know when you're in charge of a
company people usually hate their boss
because they're mean all the time you
know humor is a great tool to use to
just get people on your side
[Music]